i heard a list from gary i was listening
to this last night and i gotta say i did
agree with gary oh really what was this
list gary's least favorite sexual
positions i thought this was pretty
interesting well the complicated ones i
don't want like let's not play [ __ ]
twister reverse cowgirl i don't like um
standing sex i don't like i think that's
stupid sex in a pool is a waste of time
sex in the shower is a waste of time
agreed that's good gary that i agree
with you sex in a pool is the dumbest
[ __ ] thing ever first of all it's dry
a woman has natural juices as ronnie
says you try to go in there with the
pool water
it's not fun
and a shower forget about it i start
shaking like a leaf because i'm chilled
i'm not under the water someone's always
cold yeah and you know what i'm selfish
i push the woman away from the shower
the woman's gonna be cold not you like
oh i'm cold
i know some dudes they're so horny
nothing slows them down when we talk to
the gathering of the juggalos those guys
that will have sex with women in a porta
potty that's like hardcore
hey ronnie says he likes pool sex but
it's not at figures right see ronnie's
an animal
ronnie you don't find that your dick and
the woman's vagina dries out no not
really because she's so turned on
that there's no problem getting in and
the great part about doing in the pool
she's kind of like weightless in the
water so you could like really move her
around her up and down and it's kind of
fun it figures ronnie's into it you got
to get it really turned on first well
how am i going to do that forget it then
yeah forget it that's too much work